en los casos que han registrado Cuál es
el denominador común que permite estos
abusos de fuerza y en qué contexto se
producen a mayormente las agresiones
bueno muchas muchas gracias por la
invitación Buenas tardes es importante
mencionar que frente al contexto en el
que sucedieron los hechos encontramos
que el 40% de estos casos sucedieron en
contexto de protesta esto nos preocupa
porque a pesar de que se haya dado hace
la creación de una unidad de diálogo y
mantenimiento que hace parte del proceso
de transformación Social propuesto para
el gobierno Pedro Pues siguen ocurriendo
hechos de violencia policial en medio de
la protesta social y nos llama la
atención que en medio del contexto de
protesta social ya registramos un caso
de trauma ocular desde temblores
consideramos que una fuerza pública Que
respete los Derechos Humanos no puede
recaer en prácticas que ya se venían
denunciando como los traumas oculares
luego de este contexto cuando se suman
otros contextos como ocio trabajo
tránsito transporte nos damos cuenta que
estos son hechos que ocurren en
contextos cotidianos en espacio público
y suman un 47% del total esto evidencia
que como hemos insistido desde temblores
pues la reforma policial también debe
contemplar los contextos cotidianos
porque la violencia policial no solo
ocurre en contexto de protesta sino que
también se materializa en el espacio
público en medio de actividades
cotidianas claro le pregunto
precisamente por lo que usted ya estaba
mencionando por esta intención
gubernamental de transformar la policía
le preguntó puestos en contexto y
respecto a las administraciones
anteriores la llegada de Petro a la
presidencia ha supuesto un cambio real
en la actuación de la fuerza pública
pues desde nuestra organización
consideramos que si hay un cambio en el
discurso que hay algunos lineamientos
que muestran que hay una conciencia
sobre el respeto a la protesta y sobre
una policía que está al servicio de la
ciudadanía que estoy atravesada por
enfoques no militaristas y que pues
represente más bien un papel civil en la
sociedad sin embargo pues estos reporten
nos muestra que todavía hay muchas
transformaciones por hacer que los casos
se siguen presentando y digamos algo que
nos preocupa mucho de este reporte son
los casos de violencia homicida que
registramos en nuestro reporte porque de
los cuatro hechos de violencia homicidas
registrados tres ocurrieron en contexto
de privación de libertad esto muestra
que no nos está garantizando la vida de
las personas que el estado tiene Bajo su
custodia y no es un hecho aislado sino
que corresponde a toda una crisis en los
centros de detención específicamente en
las estaciones de policía donde hay
altos niveles de hacinamiento y donde se
recaen en vulneraciones de los Derechos
Humanos de las personas que allí se
encuentran Entonces digamos
reconocemos que hay voluntad pero que
hay muchas transformaciones todavía que
deben materializarse en una
transformación mucho más amplia que
impacte pues en el en el accionar
cotidiano de la de la fuerza pública